the most important days in your life
on the day you are born
and the day you find out why
never argue with stupid people they will
drag you down to their level
and then beat you with experience
if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
the truth must be served like a coat
and not thrown in the face like a wet
towel
let us live so that when we come to die
even the undertaker will be sorry
everyone is a moon
and has a dark side which he never shows
to anybody
only two things we'll regret
on deathbed
that we are a little loved
and little traveled
keep away from people who try to
belittle your ambitions
small people always do that
but the really great make you feel that
you
too
can become great
[Music]
man will do many things to get himself
loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
wrinkles should merely indicate
where the smiles have been
if you pick up a starving dog and make
him prosperous
he will not bite you
this is the principal difference between
a dog
and man
i am an old man
and have known a great many troubles
but most of them never happened
courage is resistance to fear
mastery of fear not absence of fear
kindness is a language which the deaf
can hear
and the blind can see
all you need in this life is ignorance
and confidence
then success is sure
the man who does not read has no
advantage over the man
who cannot read
forgiveness is the fragrance that the
violet sheds on the heel that has
crushed it
[Music]
a banker is a fellow who lends you his
umbrella when the sun is shining
but wants it back the minute it begins
to rain
the fear of death follows from the fear
of life
a man who lives fully is prepared to die
at any time
[Music]
to get the full value of joy
you must have someone to divide it with
anger is an acid that can do more harm
to the vessel in which it is stored
than to anything on which it is poured
the human race has only one really
effective weapon
and that is laughter
when i was a boy of 14
my father was so ignorant i could hardly
stand to have the old man around
but when i got to be 21
i was astonished at how much the old man
had learned in seven years
eat a live frog first thing in the
morning
and nothing worse will happen to you the
rest of the day
[Music]
never argue with a fool
onlookers may not be able to tell the
difference
when i was younger
i could not remember anything
whether it had happened or not
but my faculties are decaying now
and soon i shall be so i cannot remember
any
but the things that never happened
it is sad to go to pieces like this
but we all have to do it
[Music]
noise proves nothing
often a hen who has laid an egg tackles
as if she had laid an asteroid
do something every day that you don't
want to do
this is the golden rule for acquiring
the habit of doing your duty without
pain honesty
the best of all the lost arts
be careful about reading health books
you may die of a misprint
[Music]
loyalty to country always
loyalty to government
when it deserves it
by land
they're not making it anymore
a person with a new idea is a crank
until the idea succeeds
the lack of money is the root of all
evil
giving up smoking is the easiest thing
in the world
i know because i've done it thousands of
times
[Music]
when your friends begin to flatter you
on how young you look
it's a sure sign you're getting old
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments don't
miss out on a chance to see the next
video
subscribe